Tenemos tres rectas y debemos determinar,
cuáles de ellas son paralelas.
La recta A y no puede ser paralela a sí misma,
tiene que ser paralela a otra.
La recta A, cuya ecuación está dada por,
"y" igual a 3/4 de "x" menos 4.
La recta B...
La recta B cuya ecuación está dada por "4y"
menos 20 igual a "-3x".
Y finalmente, la recta C, cuya ecuación está
dada por "-3x" más "4y" igual a 40.
Para verificar si alguna de estas rectas es
paralela a alguna de las otras,
tenemos que comparar sus pendientes.
Si cualquiera de estas dos rectas tiene la
misma pendiente y ya que son distintas rectas
pues varía su ordenada al origen, entonces
las rectas son paralelas.
Para la recta A es muy fácil identificar
su pendiente, pues está en forma pendiente ordenada,
en "mx" más "b", así es que la
pendiente es igual a 3/4,
mientras que la ordenada a la origen que es irrelevante para determinar rectas paralelas es igual a -4.
Veamos cual es la pendiente
para las otras rectas.
Esta recta no está en ninguna
de las formas conocida,
no está en la forma punto pendiente,
ni en la forma pendiente ordenada,
por lo que tenemos que manipular la ecuación para encontrar el valor de la pendiente.
Así es que vamos a despejar "y"... vamos
a despejar "y",
para eso sumamos 20 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
¿qué nos resulta entonces?
Del lado izquierdo -20 se cancela con 20,
por los cual nos queda "4y" es igual a "-3x" más 20.
Divido ahora entre 4, ambos lados de la ecuación....
divido entre 4 ambos lados de la ecuación,
del lado izquierdo tenemos, estos 4 se cancelan,
nos da "y" igual a -3/4...
-3/4 de "x" más 20/4 que es igual a 5.
La ecuación ya está en la forma pendiente
ordenada, por lo cual la pendiente es igual a -3/4.
Es diferente que la de esta recta, ésta es
-3/4 y -esta es 3/4,
así que estas rectas no son paralelas.
Vayamos ahora a la recta C.
Está en la forma general, vamos a despejar "y".
Entonces sumamos "3x" a ambos
lados de la ecuación...
sumamos "3x" a ambos lados de la ecuación,
del lado izquierdo se cancelan
las "3x", nos queda, "4y" es igual a "3x" más 40
ó 40 más "3x", es exactamente lo mismo.
Ahora, vamos a dividir ambos lados entre 4,
dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación entre 4, del lado izquierdo qué me queda,
"y" es igual a 3/4 de "x"... 3/4 de "x",  más 10
así es que para esta recta la pendiente
es igual a 3/4 y de paso determinamos
que la ordenada al origen es igual a 10.
Así es que esta recta y esta recta, son parelelas,
tienen la misma pendiente que es igual a 3/4,
son rectas distintas pues la
ordenada al origen es distinta,
así es que la recta C y la recta A son paralelas,
mientras que la recta B no
es paralela a ninguna de las otras dos.